they gathered to discuss the captives
being held in Gaza a special session of
the Israeli Parliament to show support
to air concern but as prime minister
Benjamin Netanyahu Rose the families of
those held captive in Gaza made their
voices Hur put their banners where they
knew he would see he asked for more time
we don't have it they called and as he
insisted the return of the captives was
a
priority the families chanted the word
now over and over
again to you idea Fighters and hurt
families and relatives of abductees I
say from this platform that we are not
stopping and we won't stop until
Victory nyah's comments came just hours
after he made a visit to troops on the
ground in Gaza with the number of
Israeli casualties growing the Prime
Minister warned of more long hard days
ahead we are not stopping anyone one who
talks about stopping no we will not stop
the war continues till the end until we
finish them no less than that a
three-step proposal to end the war being
pushed by the Egyptians appears to still
be on the table Hamas dismissed reports
it had rejected the plan Hamas has said
several times there can be no ceasefire
until Israel stops the war in Gaza
Israel's leaders have made it clear that
this war is going to continue with the
same intensity and in the middle the
people of Gaza are dying until peace
breaks out Alan Fischer Al jazer in
occupied East
Jerusalem make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer